genis aussi que j'aborde l'est le tour
de chant que j'attends donnait le music
hall
c'était cette formule qui est le tour de
chant le de revenir tous les ans
systématiquement avec un taux de change
établi et cetera par contre je continue
de chanter puisque je pars demain pour
une tournée
j'ai encore deux ans de contrat à
assumer que j'abandonne si vous voulez
c'est cette formule qui est devenu une
chose un petit peu comme fonctionnaire
cas si vous voulez j'ai toujours pensé
que ce métier je ne pourrais le faire
que s'ils étaient totalement ma vérité
que si un jour tout à coup je me sentais
tricher avec ce public qui m'a tant
donné avec ce qui est ma vie je ne
pourrais pas continuer comme ça c'est à
dire que tout à coup j'ai envie de
bouger
j'ai fait tout ce que j'avais envie de
faire comme j'avais envie de le faire
avec toutes les maladresses se comporter
avec toutes les erreurs et puis
maintenant j'ai envie de partir j'avais
pas décidé de partir ça m'est arrivé
comme ça ces jours ci j'ai senti ça
alors j'ai eu envie de le dire et je lui
dit hier soir en selle
parce que je voulais pas qu'on la prenne
si vous voulez par d'autres que par mois
vous
je ne suis pas quelqu'un je n'ai jamais
eu aucune imagination
je lui ai toujours dit je ne suis pas
quelqu'un qui écrit je ne suis pas un
poète
j'ai écrit petitement avec la petite vie
de femme de chaque jour avec mes drame
avec mes morts avec mes amours béchir
est heureuse je ne suis pas quelqu'un de
triste il s'est trouvé que les gens se
sont retrouvés dans les choses tristes
je voudrais même goût du coeur
j'ai écrit avec chaque matin avec chaque
nuit avec chaque chose qui m'est arrivé
nous disons que ce n'est pas donné à
tout le monde
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas pourquoi
pourquoi pas je m'en vais je verrai bien
ce métier a ceci de merveilleux qu'il
est une aventure il faut être nomade
qu'il faut recommencer chaque jour